[Musica]
il mio tetto all che avverte sull'ansia
e già questo la dice molto lunga sul mio
stato in questo momento quindi
milan
riconoscete la lettera alle mie spalle
probabilmente è un account è una cannes
corsivo maiuscola probabilmente l'ultima
volta che l'avete vista facevate ancora
lì elementari il corsivo minuscolo ma
peggio ancora quello maiuscolo è una
delle tante competenze che mi sono state
trasmesse in questi 35 anni di vita che
non si sono rivelate proprio necessarie
se dovessi fare una top three un podio
immaginario ci affiancherà i da una
parte le divisioni a due cifre e
dall'altra la memorizzazione
dell'incipit della divina commedia
vi dico la verità a volte questi 35 anni
mi pesano come se fossero il doppio ma
quello che ci siano stasera tra il
pubblico dei giovani esponenti
dell'agenzia o qualunque altra lettera
si utilizzi per quelle successive
ecco sappiate che quando andavo a scuola
io le calcolatrici erano già inventate
già esistevano e gusto perché aveva già
inventato la stampa
perciò memorizzare dei brani per quanto
i mortai e del chelsea era quantomeno
superflua
ma perchè vi sto mostrando un acca
maiuscola in corsivo è perché con lei
che è cominciata la mia ansia
avevo solo 7 anni e facevo la seconda
alimentare in una scuola privata di roma
di proprietà di un gruppo di religiosi i
padri scolopi per la precisione forse
per scontare questo privilegio
contrariamente ai nostri compagni della
scuola pubblica alla fine di ogni anno
scolastico dovevamo sostenere un esame
e come se non fosse abbastanza veniva
anche il commissario esterno
la maestra cominciava a gennaio a farci
terrorismo psicologico
dipingendo il commissario esterno come
esigentissimo illustrissimo pignolissimo
tantissime altre cose che finiscono in
issimo e in un attimo l'esame di seconda
elementare si tramutava nella selezione
per accedere alla normale di pisa fai
una cosa del genere oggi a un bambino
come minimo ta restano a quei tempi era
considerata pedagogia
non mi stupisce quindi che tutti gli
studenti fossero letteralmente
terrorizzati e si sa che quando la gente
è terrorizzata iniziano a fioccare le
leggende metropolitane o quelle che oggi
chiamiamo fei news per girare voce con
una bambina l'anno precedente e fateci
caso sono sempre femmine del sciagurate
anche nelle narrazioni fittizia
insomma la bambina era stata bocciata da
l'intransigentismo commissario esterno
perché aveva dimenticato di mettere il
trattino sulla cabrio scola
pensateci bene
un misero trattino aveva pregiudicato
per sempre la sua carriera scolastica
non sapevo ancora darle un nome ma
passare settimane successive che mi
separavano dall'esame in preda a una
vera e propria ansia paralizzante non
importava quanto studiassi o quanto
costi dirigente nei compiti ero convinta
che sarebbe bastato un misero errore di
distrazione come quello a pregiudicare
tutto il risultato ea quel punto cosa
sarebbe successo sarei stata bocciata
avrei fatto vergognare la mia famiglia
la mia maestra la mia scuola gli scolopi
mi avrebbero detto ecco è per colpa tua
che gesuiti si credono stop sono i
migliori nel campo dell'istruzione
[Applauso]
quello che non sapevo quando avevo sette
anni è che non si può controllare
l'incontrollabile non si può prevedere
l'imprevedibile e non è neanche sempre
vera quella legge di murphy e per cui se
qualcosa può andare storto allora lo
farò senz'altro ma io come una specie di
cassandra applicato questo principio di
catastrofismo al grosso della mia
esistenza provando a rispondere
all'ansia con il controllo e più provavo
a esercitare il controllo e più
inevitabilmente una estate notando
stasera peraltro falliva
ecco si confermava la mia idea la mia
logica disfunzionale per cui avevo avuto
ragione a sottovalutarli
contenta poi mi ostinavo a paragonare la
mia vita con quelle degli altri che mi
apparivano perfette senza problemi di
sorta o mentre io a 7 anni già facevo i
conti con la bruciante sensazione del
fallimento fallimento che non era ancora
avvenuto ma era solo questione di tempo
adesso voi vorrete sapere com'è andato
il mio same di seconda elementare o
forse vi volete far rimborsare il
biglietto cosa che francamente non mi
stupirebbe ecco è andato bene sono stata
promossa o certo tutte le volte che
delinea polacca maiuscola avevo un
mancamento ma il trattino quello ce lo
mettevo sempre negli anni mi sono
erroneamente convinta fosse andato bene
proprio per quello perché non avevo
dimenticato il trattino o il controllo
aveva funzionato
questa esperienza mi ha indubbiamente
temperata no nel senso che mi ha
trasformato nella persona iper
meticolosa che mi piace descrivere
colloqui quando cerco di farmi assumere
doveste vedermi gli occhi degli
intervistatori che filù minano quando
dico loro un mio difetto
sono troppo precisa
dall'altra parte mi ha reso una persona
fondamentalmente è molto insicura
io ero talmente insicura che non pensavo
di avere banalmente la sindrome
dell'impostore come adesso dicono molti
io pensavo di essere l'unica vera
imposte ici anche perché parliamoci
chiaro ma statisticamente
esisteranno più impostori o persone con
la sindrome dell'impostore ci siamo
capiti
negli anni successivi ho cambiato scuola
sempre scuola privata ma questa volta è
abbastanza scuola religiosa ma questa
volta è mia non hanno badato a spese
erano i best in class i gesuiti
mi sentivo un po in colpa nei confronti
degli scolopi come quando cambi lavoro e
va dalla concorrenza come i calciatori
che vengono fischiati dalla loro
precedente curva quali sono miliardari
sai che gli frega io negli anni
successivi
non ero più un'ansiosa amatoriale ero
diventata una vera e propria campionessa
d'ansia ero passata all'agonismo gli
anni della h del trattino come sull'ac
mi sembravano così lontani così
spensierati
c'erano molte più cose di cui
preoccuparsi nel mondo di una bambina di
quart alimentare a cominciare dalla
prima comunione primo vero spartiacque
della nostra esistenza
allora la comunione si svolgeva a scuola
perché come vedete dalla foto c'era nel
complesso una chiesa anche di discrete
dimensioni
la ministra tutti i gesuiti ci avevano
messo tanta di quell'ansia
sull'organizzazione di questa benedetta
comunione che quando mi sono sposata in
confronto è stata una passeggiata di
salute
mi ricordo che la gente mi diceva ma
gaia di sposi tra due settimane a parte
auguri a ma specie stata agevole roma la
roma io ho fatto la comunione
da quel momento è poi tutta discesa
la comunione o ve ne parlo
c'era innanzitutto lo scoglio della
prima confessione
che sembrava solo all'apparenza facile
bisognava fare altro che dipingersi come
una persona orribile e quello
perdonatemi se mi vanto ero già
bravissima
preparare un elenco di peccatucci
irrisori che all'epoca mi sembravano
imperdonabili risposto male a mio padre
mi sono accapigliata con mia sorella non
avevo voglia di fare i compiti o poi
però li ho fatti lo stesso ma non avevo
voglia
la parte che mi preoccupava di più era
dover recitare ad alta voce l'atto di
dolore davanti al padre confessore
dimostrandogli di averlo correttamente
imparato a memoria
e badate bene che non era mica un frate
qualunque era il preside della scuola
che per l'occasione assumeva ruolo di
nostro primo confessore ecco ricordo che
quel giorno ero talmente agitata perché
avevo paura di dimenticare parti della
preghiera o sbagliare le parole che
l'atto di dolore io lo ho recitato come
col 2 per sul workshop mio dio vivente
mi tolgo tutto il cuore i miei peccati
perché perché hanno meritato molto più
per copioso the
passato lo scoglio della confessione il
resto della comunione era un incubo a
livello di logistica e di rigorose
istruzioni ricevute
la maestra cha va tenuto a dirci che
doveva essere un evento dei più solenni
dovevamo attraversare la navata in
silenzio
rigorosamente in ordine di altezza e io
ero anche la prima
dovevamo essere serissimi ma anche
gioiosi perché la comunione una festa ma
contriti non guardare in faccia nessuno
non salutare i nostri genitori non
scambiare se thor dc gesti di pace
alla fine se non fosse stato per loro e
luglio hallelujah faremo sembrati tutti
degli animali impagliati
c'era poi un fattore esterno che mi
preoccupava particolarmente potevo
garantire per me stessa non potevo
garantire pure per i miei parenti e se
mio zio ha detto al filmino dal momento
del mio ingresso avessi iniziato ad
agitare le mani urlando a bella io cosa
che peraltro mia madre va pure paventato
come ne farei uscita a quali altri
ordini sacerdotali avrei potuto affidare
la mia istruzione
come al solito mi stavo ponendo un
problema inutile non solo mio zio quel
giorno si è comportato come carlo
d'inghilterra ma io ne ho tratto un
altra lezione
possiamo controllare a malapena noi
stessi figuriamoci gli altri
non sto qui a raccontarvi tutti i
momenti in cui ho fatto i conti con
imprevedibilità non basterebbe il tempo
a mia disposizione e soprattutto sono
meno divertenti
più si va avanti negli anni più i miei
tentativi di esercitare il controllo
assumono delle sfumature più tristi e
più cupe ho controllato il cibo ho
controllato il peso non mi sono voluta
bene e questo ha avuto un impatto nelle
mie scelte
nelle mie relazioni di meninos aratori
plurale
ma una cosa posso e devo dirvelo come ne
sono uscita come ha imparato a fare i
conti con il fatto che ci sono sempre
cose ci saranno sempre cose che
sfuggiranno il nostro controllo e non
possiamo fare altro che prendere il
meglio da quello che abbiamo
correndo dei rischi e sapendo che
qualunque esito negativo possa
verificarsi non impatterà mai il nostro
valore come persona
io credo tantissimo nell'importanza
della psicoterapia e credo che stia
facendo la differenza per le persone
della mia generazione
e nonostante non sia più considerato un
tabù da tempo siamo spesso noi i primi
che non vogliono ricorrere perché ci
recriminiamo di non essere abbastanza
forti ecco nel mio caso non sarebbe
bastato essere forte
così come non è bastato incasellare
qualche discreto successo quella io
potrei diventare presidentessa dell'ong
domani è ovviamente un iperbole l'onu
non è che a messa così male
manco benissimo ultimamente però insomma
non basterebbe a dimostrarmi che valgo
qualcosa come persona esattamente come
non sono bastate le parole d'affetto e
di stima dimmi chi mi circondava nel
corso degli anni che ho bisogno di fare
un percorso
non semplice non immediato con una
figura professionale che mi aiutasse a
cambiare l'idea che avevo di me stessa
la psicoterapia uno strumento potente
perché ti permette di guardare alla
realtà attraverso un filtro diverso da
quello che usiamo quotidianamente e
attenzione non quello della positività
atossica tutto rose e fiori ma quello
della consapevolezza del nonostante
tutto del va bene lo stesso la terapia
ti permette di diventare l'adulto di cui
avresti avuto bisogno quando qualcosa è
andato storto
mettendo in relazione il presente con il
passato è la cosa più simile un viaggio
nel tempo si possa fare ecco io credo
che gli psicoterapeuti dovrebbero fare
così marketing cioè non mask salutaci
marte noi andiamo negli anni 90 si sta
da dio peraltro le cause sono grandi
anche il doppio rispetto a quelle di
oggi
mentirei se vi dicessi
il problema si è risolto completamente
certi automatismi sono difficili da
scardinare quando mi hanno proposto di
fare questo tetto all che la prima cosa
che ho pensato è stata sono pazzi e la
seconda è stata fanno raschiando il
fondo del barile
ma ma
io credo con dosi di insicurezza sia
importante mantenerla nella vita perché
credo che sia un po come il veleno che
sia sorto in piccole dosi
paradossalmente non solo non ti uccide
ma può anche farti del bene e ho
imparato questo in terapia a utilizzare
l'insicurezza come una potente alleata
mi ha poi aiutato anche a gestire un
sacco di situazioni del quotidiano
piccole o grandi che siano vi faccio un
esempio banale un tempo quando qualcuno
mi faceva una domanda e io magari non
avevo sentito cosa che è pazzo sarà
capitato anche a voi io andavo
letteralmente nel panico adesso chiedo
con grande disinvoltura di ripetere o
poi certo se anche la seconda volta
ancora non ho sentito faccio finta di
aver capito improvviso qualcosa
come tutte le persone normali
[Applauso]